i i do i i know that we have a lot of
stressful things going on
as of this moment we don't know who is
going to be the next president of the
united states
but i want to take a moment just to say
something
happy um we had an
incredible turnout of force in the
independent progressive media community
yesterday
we set records on every platform our
we estimate that 1.5 million different
people watched
some part of our election results
coverage last night
we had over up to 82
83 000 live concurrent viewers on
youtube
with a sum total of about 1.4 million
different people
coming in and out throughout the evening
a record for us incredible
uh ungodly numbers of comments and
and messages from everybody just
completely unbelievable
uh we had four to seven thousand people
throughout the night on twitch which is
another platform that we've been taking
very seriously it's been a great place
to do
politics not historically not the place
for politics more for gaming and other
types of content
we are there and a few others are there
doing politics on twitch an incredible
night
in total view time by far a record on
twitch
um 400 paid subscribers signing up via
the twitch
platform another 400 members signing up
on our website so
the this is what what matters is
do we remove donald trump and we don't
know that yet
but the way that our community has come
out and
spent the evening with us and with me it
was a long night
it was a stressful night during which i
tried to encourage
uh people to to remain calm um but
what an incredible evening and um
now the question is can we continue if
we the
goal is the idea would be that if we can
remove donald trump we still don't know
we're still waiting on results if trump
can be removed
my goal would be the dream would be that
all of this growth that we've been
experiencing
gives us a much stronger position from
which to now
do progressive activism if we remove
donald trump
we've been playing a lot of defense the
last four years we may have to play
defense for another four
by the time you watch today's show or
listen to this clip you might already
know the winner
but the opportunity is if we can remove
donald trump
to leverage our larger than ever
audience thanks to you
thanks to you really um to get the most
we can out of whatever opportunity
presents itself
to move things to the left in the united
states so a huge
huge thank you again our estimate more
than 1.5
million different people joined us on
youtube
twitch our facebook stream and we were
also the live
facebook stream for our broadcast
partner free speech tv
really really incredible so we're going
to continue counting vote counting votes
um at some point in the next day two
three four days
we will have a likely winner we have a
fantastic bonus show for you for you
today i'm told pat
barely slept so we will hear from him
we're going to look at
what we do know from yesterday including
ballot initiatives
including some of the key senate and
house races
and so much more about what to expect in
the coming
sort of like the day the week
the two and a half months until january
20th
and the next four years those are the
different time frames that we're looking
at right now so
come on in grab yourself a membership at
joinpakman.com it takes very little time
you'll get instant access to the members
only bonus show
and there is much to discuss so i look
forward to seeing you then